hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
Außenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock und
eine Delegation aus Unternehmern und
Journalist in Muster auf dem Weg in den
Pazifikraum jetzt zum zweiten Mal
pannenbedingt in Abu Dhabi
zwischenlanden weil es eben einen
technischen Defekt an einer
Regierungsmaschine gab die Reise sollte
eigentlich nach Australien gehen die ist
aber mittlerweile komplett abgesagt
worden wie reagiert Anna-Lena Bär wird
darauf lasst uns mal einen Blick drauf
werfen sie sagt hier auf X wir haben
alles versucht leider ist es logistisch
nicht möglich meine indopazifikreise
ohne den defekten Flieger fortsetzen das
ist mehr als
ärgerlich ja Ärger also bei der
Außenministerin und es ist nicht das
erste Mal dass eine Panne am
regierungsflieger Anna-Lena Bock daran
hindert eine Reise zu machen und das
wollen wir uns heute die Frage stellen
wie flugbereit ist eigentlich die
deutsche Flugbereitschaft ist sie
vielleicht nur bedingt flugbereit und
das versuchen wir heute zu klären und
zwar mit hauptstadtkorrespondent Daniel
pantzen der mit an Bord war und aktuell
noch in Abu Dhabi gestrandet ist und mit
luftfahrtexperte Andreas spät mit dem
wir so ein bisschen über das Flugzeug
und die Flugbereitschaft generell
sprechen und wie immer sprechen wir auch
mit euch wenn ihr fragen habt an meine
zwei Gäste oder eure Meinung zum Thema
mit uns teilen wird dann schreibt uns
gerne hier im Youtube Chat oder per Mail
an die eingeblendete Adresse jetzt
spreche ich aber erstmal mit Daniel
pontzen der uns live aus Abu Dhabi
zugeschaltet ist hallo Daniel
ist ein gutes Stichwort das stimmt
übrigens sogar wörtlich denn hier gibt's
ja im Stand man sieht nicht hinter mir
ist schon dunkel ist aber ja so schlimm
ist das ja alles nicht
okay da sind wir froh dass es dir
halbwegs gut geht ich habe es gerade
schon gesagt du warst gestern im
Flugzeug das jetzt ein zweites mal ein
paar unbedingt wieder auf den Boden
zurückkommen musste wie war denn da die
Stimmung an Bord
also ehrlich gesagt in dem ersten Moment
als das alle realisierten das ist jetzt
schon wieder nicht so hoch und so
schnell geht wie eigentlich gewollt da
war Ungläubigkeit eigentlich das
Zentrale des dominierende Gefühl bei den
meisten denn es gab natürlich keinen der
vorher nicht irgendeinen Spruch gemacht
hat irgendeinen Witz nach dem Motto
jetzt wird das doch bestimmt wieder so
kommen aber eigentlich waren sich alle
sicher das wird jetzt nicht so passieren
weil ja eben
strengeprüft wurde vorher hatte sogar
ein Probeflug gegeben und vor allen
Dingen waren aus einem Grunde alle
sicher dass diesmal gut gehen würde weil
man nämlich davon ausgehen dass man die
Ministerin jetzt nicht ein zweites Mal
in die Luft schicken würde ohne wirklich
sicher zu sein dass es gut gehen würde
ein Gefühl der Angst deswegen habe ich
das gerade eingangs auch gesagt so
schlimm ist das alles gar nicht ein
Gefühl der Angst hatte eigentlich
niemand dass er höchstens beim ersten
mal so ein bisschen mulmig wenn man da
noch nicht wusste womit man es zu tun
hat das hat mir dann ja nach dem ersten
mal gelernt dass das kein
Sicherheitsrisiko darstellt aber es war
natürlich auch viele einfach schlecht
enttäuscht dass diese Reise nicht wie
geplant den fortgesetzt werden können
Sie zunächst ähm versuchte die
Delegation dann ja noch die Reise
trotzdem noch per Linienflug durch ähm
vorzusetzen das hat sich dann ein paar
Stunden später aber auch zerschlagen
insofern ja musste vielleicht zum
späteren Zeitung nachgeholt werden
das ist ganz lustig ihr schreibt auch
gerade jemand auf Youtube warum gibt es
in solchen Fällen nicht einen Plan B
einfach ins Reisebüro und einen Flug
nach Neuseeland buchen das hat man also
versucht ja
den gab es den gab sogar schon am Tag
zuvor und
das hat möglicherweise auch zu der ein
oder anderen Verstimmung in der
Delegation um Außenministerin Werbung
geführt dass man nämlich eine
Alternative gehabt hätte man hatte schon
vorher in Linienflug hätte man sicher
gehabt mit dem man nach Sydney hätte
fliegen können eine Stadt ein zweites
Mal diesen Versuch von avidad Abu Dhabi
aus zu unternehmen aber dann gab es eben
die Ansage der Flugbereitschaft nee wir
haben jetzt gerade getestet und es ist
ziemlich safe nach allem was wir sagen
können also Safe in dem Sinne dass das
klappen sollte und da waren natürlich
viele in der Delegation nicht glücklich
weil hätte man sich da für die andere
Variante entschieden dann wär man jetzt
tatsächlich aller Voraussicht nach innen
du und dein Kameramann ihr habt
tatsächlich auch Material aus dem
Flieger von dem Moment wo ich gestern
diese Durchsage eine erneuten
technischen da mal reinschauen
Fluggäste wir sitzen gerade am Kreises
Siegen unseres tatsächlich leider das
gleiche Problem was wir gestern hatten
wieder passiert die Klappen Vergrößerung
Geflügel von größerung lassen sich nicht
mehr einfahren sie haben sich wieder
gesperrt wir müssen uns mit unserer
Homebase und mit technischen Personal
auseinandersetzen und versuchen
rauszufinden wie wir das Flugzeug denn
überhaupt wieder nach Deutschland
bekommen
tut mir leid dass das jetzt zweimal
passiert ist
wir haben ja gelesen ich mache das schon
ein paar Jahre aber sowas ist äh auch in
der Geschichte der Fußballmannschaft
noch nicht passiert tut mir leid dass
sie dann jetzt heute abend noch mal den
Abo da gelassen und schlafen müssen
ja da wird unter den Journalisten so ein
bisschen unglaublich gelacht auch der
Pilot ist relativ überrascht wie hat
denn die Außenministerin selbst darauf
reagiert dass sie diese Reise jetzt
nicht antreten kann
also
insgesamt sehr diplomatisch sie ist ja
auch die Chef Diplomat sind sozusagen
also ihr habt da jetzt irgendwie keine
keine Wutrede oder ähnliches gar nicht
sie wusste natürlich auch dass es der
Crew den Kapitän insbesondere der das
auch alles minuzius erklärt hat und sehr
geduldig war und dem das natürlich auch
unangenehmsten war aber der schlicht
auch nichts dafür konnte und und die
Maschine dann ja auch zweimal sicher
gelandet hat hat sie das auch niemand
zum Vorwurf gemacht trotzdem war ihr
Ärger natürlich schon ein großer selbst
geschrieben ist sehr sehr ärgerlich weil
sie ja mit der Reise was bezwecken
wollte
einige Dinge die geplant waren die
geschehen sollten auf dieser Reise die
werden jetzt trotzdem durchgeführt zum
Beispiel die Rückgabe von Kulturgütern
war geplant das wird jetzt durchgezogen
auch ohne Ministerin schlicht aus dem
Grunde dass der ähm viele Menschen seit
sehr sehr langer Zeit drauf warten
sehensüchtigst und da jetzt nicht noch
mehr Zeit ins Land gehen soll eine
zweite Sache ist eine
botschaftseröffnung
einfach die wird jetzt auch vollzogen
auch ohne Ministerin das heißt die
Arbeit kann da beginnen das heißt da
gibt es jetzt faktisch keine wirklichen
Konsequenzen aber politisches Hauptziel
war ja ein Signal zu senden in diese
Region
an einer Bärbel Katze dazu jetzt auch im
heutigen twittert die Induktion oder
kurz vor der Absage Abreise auch gesagt
die Indopazifik Region werde die
Weltordnung des 21 jahrhunderts
entscheiden prägen deswegen wollte sie
eben unbedingt zu den wertepartnern wie
sie die Länder nannte zu denen sie hin
wollte Austral Neuseeland und die Inseln
und hatte das eigentlich schon seit
längerem vor hat diesen Besuch extra
noch eine Weile herausgezögert weil sie
warten wollte bis die China Strategie
der Bundesregierung vorliegt das war
jetzt der Fall vor einiger Zeit und
jetzt sollte es endlich soweit sein und
deswegen war es für sie natürlich sehr
ärgerlich dass sie diese Signal eben nur
nicht senden konnte
ja und genauer auf die Gründe für diese
Reise gucken wir gleich noch mal Daniel
ähm wir hören uns gleich noch mal
wir schauen jetzt aber erstmal auf die
Rahmenbedingungen solcher
regierungsflüge denn die Bundesregierung
fliegt ja wir haben es eben gehört
eigentlich nicht normale Linienflüge
dafür gibt es eben die Bundeswehr
Flugbereitschaft wer genau die ist wo
sie angedockt ist was sie macht und wer
eigentlich mitfliegen darf das hat sich
meine Kollegin Sarah Lazar von uns
angeschaut
sie bringt die wichtigsten deutschen
Politiker in die ganze Welt die
Flugbereitschaft sie ist Teil der
deutschen Luftwaffe und gehört zum
Verteidigungsministerium im Cockpit
sitzen bundeswehrpiloten
zur Flotte gehören unter anderem 16
Flugzeuge fünf davon sind große
Langstreckenmaschinen damit Reisen
Kanzler Bundespräsident und Co und sie
sind so ausgestattet dass auch
Delegationen etwa Wirtschaftsvertreter
und Journalisten mitfliegen können die
Vorteile die regierungsmaschinen heben
nach dem Terminplan der Politiker ab
auch wenn ein Treffen mal länger dauert
und Länder in die es keine Linienflüge
gibt können angesteuert werden auch
Krisengebiete
doch bei den Flaggschiffen der
Flugbereitschaft wie die Bundeswehr sie
selbst nennt läuft nicht immer alles
Rund zum Beispiel 2018 bei einer Reise
von Olaf Scholz knabberten Nagetiere
Elektrokabel an
Angela Merkel musste Linie zum
G20-Gipfel nach Argentinien fliegen
Verteilerbox kaputt und
2019 Heiko Maas damals Außenminister
hatte gleich drei Pannen in nur drei
Monaten
jüngst hinzugekommen Anna-Lena baerbock
für das einstige Flaggschiff den Airbus
A340 bedeutet das jetzt das vorzeitige
Aus
ja und über diesen Airbus A340 sprechen
wir jetzt und zwar mit luftfahrtexperte
Andreas spät hallo Herr Späth schön dass
Sie bei uns sind schönen guten Abend
ja vielleicht können sie uns noch mal
kurz ins Bild holen wir haben gerade
schon in diesem Video gesehen da schien
irgendwas mit den Landeklappen nicht in
Ordnung zu sein was ist das für ein
Problem und wie gängig ist das also das
Problem ist überhaupt nicht ging ich
hatte auch der Pilot schon selbst an
Bord in beiden Nächten den Passagiere
erklärt dass er das selber noch nie
erlebt habe in 35 Jahren in dieser
Branche als Pilot und mir geht es
ähnlich ich bin auch schon ganz lange in
dieser Branche und ich habe auch noch
nie gesehen das heißt es auf jeden Fall
kein gängiges Problem dass die
Landeklappen und die auch keine Zeit für
den Start ausgefahren werden aber eben
sofort nach dem Start wieder einfahren
müssen um sozusagen den Flügel die
optimale Form zu geben um dann eben auch
am Reiseflug nicht so viel Widerstand zu
verursachen in dieser Widerstand der
Grund dass man nicht so weit fliegen
kann weil einfach so wenn es ausgefahren
bleibt der Flügel sozusagen runter hängt
nach hinten kann man auf den Bildern
sehen wie die Maschine am Boden steht
mit den hinten runter hängen den für
klappen was normalerweise nicht
passieren sollte aber die eben massiven
Luftwiderstand erhöhen und deswegen eben
halt einen Spritverbrauch also kann man
auf keinen Fall mit so einem Flugzeug
nach Australien fliegen
ja also besser dass dann da doch noch
mal gelandet wurde und da fragt man sich
natürlich automatisch wer wartet
eigentlich diese Flugzeuge das fragt
auch Alfred Maurus auf YouTube wo und
von wem werden die Flieger der
Flugbereitschaft gewartet kann man da
über Schadensersatz reden
also die großen Flugzeuge von denen wir
jetzt gerade sprechen also die großen
airbus-typen A 340 A350 aber auch die
kleineren Airbusse die jetzt fliegen die
werden bei Lufthansa Technik gewartet
also der wartungs-tochter von Lufthansa
und da kann man schon davon ausgehen
dass es auf dem höchsten Niveau passiert
ich bin ja auch selbst schon in Hamburg
sitze hier in Hamburg auch schon bei
denen in der Werkshalle gewesen hatte
sogar große Vergnügen so halbwegs
heimlich in die damalige erste A350 mit
hinein zu schlüpfen weil keine
Journalisten rein sollten und mir auch
so ein bisschen ein damaliges
Anfangsmodell dieser vip-kabine für die
Politiker anzusehen das war für mich
Erlebnis war muss ich sagen
aber klar ist eben das hat eigentlich
von der Erwartung her hohes Niveau also
daran glaube ich liegt es nicht zumal
eben im aktuellen Problem auch
vermutlich ein Computer schuld war und
der Pilot hat ja auch gesagt dass er auf
dem Video hören können dass er selber
und auch konsultierte Lufthansa Piloten
und Lufthansa erwartungstechniker keine
Ahnung haben von weitem jedenfalls was
das eigentliche Problem ist weil es eben
auch so selten ist
okay wir wissen also nicht genau was das
Problem war bekannt ist ja aber dass
ungefähr 80 Tonnen kyosin erstmal
abgelassen werden mussten von diesem
Flugzeug damit die Maschine überhaupt
landen kann vielleicht können Sie uns
diesen Vorgang mal einordnen ist das ein
ein gängiger Vorgang was passiert da
genau warum macht man das und vor allem
wie umweltschädlich ist das ja das tue
ich gerne also da ist es ganz anders als
bei den Problemen mit den Flügelklappen
die wir eben besprochen haben denn das
Ablassen von Sprit um vorzeitig landen
zu können ist eine sehr gängige
Verfahrensweise in Luftfahrt das kommt
auch in Deutschland pro Jahr über 100
mal vor
den großen Flug irgendwie Frankfurt vor
allen Dingen das macht man dann ist auch
im exakt so vorgesehen es gibt sieht man
hier auf der Video gerade ganz gut
hinten eben an der an dieser
flügelstrebe ist eine Auslassventil oder
im herreise Erkennen dieser Strahl auch
rauskommt und das ist eben die
Möglichkeit Kerosin abgeschlossen denn
ein Flugzeug wenn es kurz nach dem Start
vollgetankt dann plötzlich wieder landen
soll ungeplanter Weise ist es zu schwer
und würde sich im schlimmsten Fall
sozusagen aufeinanderbauen zerlegen weil
es eben zu schwer ist für die Landung
und um eben das Mindestgewicht das
Höchstgewicht für die Landungen zu
erreichen muss man eben sozusagen
Ballast abwerfen deswegen ist es nötig
diese Funktion zu aktivieren und das
passiert eben durchaus relativ
regelmäßig im Luftverkehr wenn es
einfach Unregelmäßigkeiten gibt ist mir
auch selbst schon passiert in einem
Jumbo Jet aber dann eben ein Problem
gehabt technische Art zurückkehren auf
den anfangs Flughafen und dann wird das
gemacht und das ist überhaupt kein
Problem das ist weder gefährlich es ist
auch es gibt auch Untersuchungen auch
dazu Umweltbundesamt oder auch diverse
parlamentarische Anfragen dazu ob das
jetzt oder Flughafen und Umgebung sehr
umweltschädlich sei also alle
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse die ich
dazu gesehen habe sagen ziemlich
eindeutig das Kerosin zerstäubt so fein
in der Luft dass sie sich eben so fein
auch sozusagen zerlegt dass man am Boden
nicht mehr nachweisen kann und das finde
ich quasi sich verflüchtigt in der Luft
okay anscheinend nicht umweltschädlich
verbraucht ist es damit natürlich
trotzdem hier fragt jemand aus der
Community das ist eine Frage die sich
wahrscheinlich auch gerade viele Stellen
hatte die Flugbereitschaft denn kein
weiteres Flugzeug dass sie hätte
hinterherschicken können und da frage
ich noch dazu wie ist es denn generell
um diese Flotte bestellt also das ist
für mich die allerwichtigste
stellt stehe und die auch die
Bundesregierung bisher nicht richtig
beantwortet hat aber glaube ich die CDU
hat sich schon in dieselbe Richtung
geäußert was auch wirklich den
berechtigte Frage ist in diesem Falle
warum gab es kein Backup warum weiß ich
nicht möglich innerhalb von zwei Tagen
von diesen zumindest im Moment soweit
ich weiß vier vorhandenen
Langstreckenflugzeugen
Großraumflugzeugen eins zu aktivieren
und sozusagen eben hinterher zu schicken
als eine Ersatzmaschine
natürlich nicht mal sechs Flugstunden
entfernt von Berlin also nicht am Ende
der Welt dass er sich ein
australienspiel gewesen aber weit weg
von daher ist es eine Rätsel und das ist
normalerweise anscheinend eben nicht an
den vielen Pannen hier auch schon
beschrieben worden und ich kann mich
selbst erinnern vor 20 30 Jahren gab es
auch schon immer wieder Flugbereitschaft
und ich habe heute mit einem ehemaligen
führenden Lufthansa Mann gesprochen der
auch diese Flugzeuge die wir heute sehen
die A3 40 nämlich von der Lufthansa an
die Flugbereitschaft verkauft hat vor
etwas gesagt 10 bis 15 Jahren und er
sagt eben auch ja das ist eben auch so
dass diese Flugzeuge viel gegen wenig
bei der Luftwaffe und es heißt ja nicht
umsonst sagt der Flugzeug und nicht
stehzeug das kann man auch deswegen gut
vergleichen weil die Lufthansa fliegt
die gleichen Maschinen A340 300 auch
immer noch und dann ist diese Probleme
nämlich nicht und insofern ist ziemlich
offensichtlich die Tatsache
vergleichsweise wenig fliegt für den
Flugzeugen persönlich gut also sie
stehen zu viel und natürlich die
Flugstunden sind sehr gering und dafür
sind sie eigentlich gar nicht ausgelegt
und deswegen gibt eben auch diese
Probleme aber dann nicht nach diesen
langjährigen Erfahrungen mit diesen
vielen Unregelmäßigkeiten für einen
Backup einen Plan B Ersatzmaschine die
bereit sind zu sorgen ist mir ein Rätsel
wenn sie mit anderen Ländern vergleichen
mit USA mit Frankreich die haben in den
meisten Fällen solche Ersatzmaschinen
bereitstehen oft fliegende über parallel
und bei der sozusagen gemeinsam an bei
einem Staat besucht und deswegen gibt es
auch dort keine Nachrichten über der
einige Probleme
ja wir haben heute übrigens auch mal
beim Verteidigungsministerium
nachgefragt warum diese alte Maschine im
Einsatz war und nicht die zwei neuen von
denen sie eben auch gesprochen haben da
gab es aber bis Redaktionsschluss keine
Antwort gestern gab es ein Statement in
dem gesagt wurde die anderen Flugzeuge
waren anderweitig beansprucht wir haben
uns das mal international angeguckt weil
es gibt ja auf der ganzen Welt solche
regierungsflotten und wir haben da
gesehen dass auch in Polen 2022 eine
Maschine mit Präsident du da auf dem Weg
in die USA umkehren musste nach Warschau
wegen einer technischen Panne 2019 in
Kanada da gab es auch ein Triebwerks
Problem in einer solchen
regierungsflotte trudo musste damit mit
einem ersatzflieger nach Hause ja wie
stehen wir denn so da im internationalen
Vergleich der regierungsflotten in
anderen Ländern gibt's da ja anscheinend
auch Probleme
auch noch mal angeschaut heute auch wer
auf der Welt oder von den wichtigen
Ländern her so gerade Kanada zum
Beispiel aber auch Frankreich und die
USA mit was für protektypen fliegen und
wie alt die sind und das Alter spielt
schon mal keine Rolle die beiden Air
Force One die die USA haben die wir auch
berühmt aus dem Fernsehen kennen oder
auch ich habe sie auch schon öfter
direkt gesehen diese über 30 Jahre alt
also ich habe schon 93 die ersten
Maschinen damals ganz neu gesehen es
sind 30 Jahre alt und werden auch
demnächst ausgemustet hätten längst
ausgemustert sein sollen aber die der
Neubau der neuen Hotel bereits in den
werkzeilen stehen bei einem Hersteller
in den USA die verzögert sich immer
wieder was riesen Probleme gibt
technische Art und Kosten Explosion aber
Tatsache ist aber US-Präsident ist nicht
überlieferant für egal wie er hieß es in
den letzten 30 Jahren dass die also
massiert Probleme gehabt hätten ähm da
ist möglicherweise einfach die
Organisationsformen andere und einfach
auch eben dieses Thematik mit Backup
Flugzeugen in Frankreich gibt es einige
neuere Maschinen aber auch Langstrecken
mit einem A33 der ist 10 Jahre alt also
das auch nicht brandneu und also wir
haben auch einige andere Maschinen die
haben sogar auch A340 noch in Frankreich
in der regierungsflug Staffel wie wir
sie ja hier in Deutschland immer noch
haben hatten muss ich sagen bis heute
also es ist definitiv nicht die Frage
was ist da wie neu das ist nicht
automatisch für das ist besser
funktioniert sieht man auch innerhalb
der Flugbereitschaft es gibt immer
wieder Vorfälle auch mit neuen
Flugzeugen vor allem mit den kleineren
die haben also auch z.B einige bombardi
global
Geschäftsreise Jets und so zehn Sitze
mit denen z.B äh vor kurzem die
Staatssekretärin im
Verteidigungsministerium die war hänge
fest weil durch die Hitze am Boden war
die Cockpitscheibe gesprungen ähm das
sind Probleme die haben irgendwie
Airlines nicht aber sie leben auch daran
dass sie Bereitschaft diese Flüge eben
als im Grunde einmalige Flüge gemacht
und nicht in der Regelmäßigkeit
größere Erfahrung hat
ja hier schreibt gerade auch ein User
auf Youtube solche Pannen kommen bei
allen Airlines vor das ist doch jetzt
eigentlich ein blöder Zufall
ja eine gewisse Weise ist es Pech also
die Sache mit diesen klappen das schon
besprochene eigentlich bisher unbekannte
Detailprobleme der Technik das ist
perfekt
davon nur gesehen halt jetzt über so wie
lange Zeit schon so viele Paaren und
dann muss ich vor allen Dingen mal
deutlicher dass er die Flugbereitschaft
verschwinden wenig fliegt mit ihrem
Flugzeugen eben gemeldet in einer
Airline das heißt pro Flug im
durchschnittlich sozusagen ungerechnet
auf die Flügel wie sieht die durchführen
diese Pannenserie das heißt im Grunde
gibt es eine extrem hohe pandate gerade
im Vergleich zu Airlines von der hängt
eben auch so ein bisschen die gestern
von der Bundesregierung immer wieder
geäußerte Aussage ja wir sind aber
genauso sicher auch genauso gut wie eine
Airline aber die ist eben keine anderen
Struktur
ja und wir haben noch eine Frage zur
Struktur hier fragt jemand auf youtube
ist der pannenflieger heute ein Beispiel
für den Rest der Bundeswehr insbesondere
der Luftwaffe weil ja die
Flugbereitschaft an
Verteidigungsministerium angeschlossen
ist
also ich bin kein Militärexperte aber
ich habe heute auch schon diversen
fachkundigen Leuten gehört eben genau
das dass das leider irgendwie ein
Paradebeispiel ist generell für Dinge
die in Deutschland nicht funktionieren
der Fall mal an beim Fußball und Ende
eben jetzt hier bei diesem Thema oder
wird das Wachstum sind wir als einziges
großes industrieren gerade schon wieder
im negativen Bereich also irgendwie ist
gerade in ganz Deutschland ein bisschen
der Wurm drin und das ist hier eben so
ein bisschen ein Sinnbild davon ähm
insofern ist das eben auch in Symbol
auch für die Bundeswehr ja aber der
natürlich auch noch lange nicht erneuert
ist und diese 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen die sind auch noch bei
weitem nicht umgesetzt und investiert
bisher also das dauert eben als solange
insofern für dich kann man das sagen sie
ein Bild ja
ja und abschließend vielleicht noch mal
die Frage was zieht man denn jetzt für
Konsequenzen bei der Flugbereitschaft
vielleicht jetzt kurzfristig also als
Ergebnis aus diesem Tag aber vielleicht
auch mittel und langfristig was muss ich
da verändern wie werden diese
ausgemusterten Maschinen jetzt
ersetzte Frage zum einen hat die
Luftwaffe heute morgen bekannt gegeben
nach diesem Desastern Abu Dhabi das eben
jetzt
vorzeitig so Jesus diese beiden noch
vorhandenen rund 25 Jahre alten A3 40
sofort ausgemustert werden das ist aber
auch ein bisschen Augenwischerei als
große Nachricht denn die aktuell
Betroffene Maschine sollte sowieso im
September unter Dienst gestellt werden
und September sind drei Wochen insofern
eine minimale Veränderung
dass die Tatsache aber dass die beiden
A3 40 berechtigterweise außer Dienst
gestellt werden wird aber eben neue
Fragen auf bei es kommt zwar demnächst
die dritte A350 das ist von diesen neuen
Flugzeugen in den Dienst aber damit
haben wir trotzdem am Ende nur drei
Flugzeuge statt vorher 4 und das ist so
wenig Kapazität und da muss definitiv
noch mehr getan werden aber überlegen
dass dieses gleiche Flugzeug was wir
heute mit Frau bärbock zum zweiten Mal
haben vorzeitig landen sehen das hat im
Jahr 2018 ein wirklich ernst
inzwischenfall gehabt wer Frau Merkel
auf dem Weg nach Buenos Aires schon in
Köln Bonn und das war wirklich eine
Notlandung runtergehen musste und damals
hat eben die damalige Ministerin von der
Leyen gesagt jetzt reicht's ihr und
jetzt verkauft sie direkt zum ersten Mal
für die Bundesregierung Fabrik neue
Langstreckenflugzeuge das sind eben
diese A350 von den letzter aber es quasi
jetzt auch in den Streckendienst geht
also die Dinge einfach lange aber ich
vermute es musste deswegen noch
mindestens eine weitere Maschine
beschafft werden
mal gucken ob die beschaffen wird ich
denke wir bleiben da dran und sie sicher
auch danke schön ja später dass sie
meine Fragen und die Frage unserer
Community beantwortet haben sehr gerne
schönen Abend schönen Abend noch
ja und wir gucken jetzt zum Schluss noch
mal auf den Grund für diese Reise die
bärburg ja jetzt nicht antreten konnte
und dazu schalte ich noch mal nach Abu
Dhabi zu unserem zdf-korrespondenten
Daniel pontzen hallo Daniel
hallo
Daniel für dich habe ich auch noch mal
eine Frage zu den Flügen erstmal gerade
gab es ja so ein bisschen Unsicherheit
darum warum es kein Ersatzflugzeug gab
das Statement des
Verteidigungsministeriums las ich auch
so ein bisschen kryptisch kannst du uns
da zu mehr sagen ja die Frage haben sich
hier natürlich auch alle gestellt und
eine offizielle Antwort gab es nicht
aber später hat ja gerade schon mal
ausgeführt wie viele Maschinen oder wie
wenige muss man eigentlich eher sagen
für die komplette Bundesregierung für
solche Langstreckenflüge oder Flüge von
dieser Reichweite zumindest zur
Verfügung stehen das sind aktuell fünf
Maschinen eben drei dieser A350 dieser
neuen Modelle und eben diese beiden
a340er die nun ausgemustert werden eben
jetzt mit sofortiger Wirkung früher als
ursprünglich geplant
und bei diesen fünf ist es so dass
ursprünglich eine andere Art 340
vorgesehen war für diesen Flug die stand
dann aus nicht näher benannten Gründen
nicht zur Verfügung es war alles also
schon sozusagen die Ersatzmaschine eine
mit der wir her geflogen sind und die
drei anderen A350 sozusagen die neueren
die besseren die bei denen ist es wohl
so dass sich eine im Moment in der Regel
Wartung befindet ja die werden eben
gehört haben immer wieder regelmäßig
gewartet bei dem anderen bei dem zweiten
was so dass die noch so neu ist dass die
gerade erst hergerichtet wird der
VIP-Bereich vorne noch eingebaut wird
deswegen nicht zur Verfügung steht und
dann gab es eben noch eine dritte
Maschine und die war wohl anderweitig
verplant an wen wissen wir nicht so
wahnsinnig viele kommen nicht in Frage
in der Höhe in der Nahrungskette als die
Außenministerin stehen eigentlich nur
noch
Bundeskanzler Bundespräsidenten
Verteidigungsminister gegebenenfalls das
wurde nicht näher spezifiziert also nach
dieser lese Abstand schlicht keine
andere Maschine zur Verfügung
und von den
flugzeuginformationen kommen wir jetzt
noch mal zu den politischen Gründen von
Annalena baerbock die eigentlich für
diese Reise gesprochen haben lasst uns
dazu noch mal auf Ihre Nachricht gucken
die sie heute bei Ex verfasst hat du
hast es gerade schon angesprochen Daniel
sie spricht ja davon dass wir im
Indopazifik nicht nur enge Freunde und
Partner haben die Region wird die
Weltordnung des 21 jahrhunderts
entscheiden prägen daher ist der
inhaltliche und persönliche Austausch so
wichtig
Daniel du hast es gerade schon
angedeutet es geht um die Eröffnung
einer Botschaft es geht um die Rückgabe
von Kulturgütern kann man diese Aufgaben
irgendwie Ranken in der Priorisierung
oder also gibt es da irgendwas was
herausgestochen hat in der Wichtigkeit
oder ist es einfach schon sehr lange her
dass da auch eine deutsche Vertretung
mal war
sowohl als auch
soll man die Rede davon dass in
Australien der letzte Außenminister
Guido Westerwelle gewesen sei ich glaube
2011 wenn ich das richtig erinnere die
Kanzlerin war wohl seither noch mal da
aber insgesamt war Deutschland da nicht
besonders präsent in dieser Region
zuletzt
emotionales Highlights und dann sind die
das so nennt sich Außenministerin das
wäre die Rückgabe der Kulturgüter
gewesen ich habe es eben schon mal kurz
ausgeführt dass das eben für viele aus
dieser indigenen Gemeinschaft in die
diese Kulturgüter zurückgegeben werden
sollte handelt sich um uralten Speer
weil und so weitere Gegenstände
unheimlich hohen emotionalen wertet aber
das viel größere politische Gewicht
hatte natürlich diese
Signale das eben gesendet werden sollte
jetzt im in ihrem Tweet genannt und
diese zunehmende Bedeutung des
innovativen Raumes die spiegelt sich ja
auch darin dass die Bundesregierung
kürzlich nicht nur eine
Sicherheitsstrategie in der nationale
gelegt hat sondern zusätzlich noch meine
china-strategie und deswegen hat sie der
Besuch hier natürlich eine hohe
Bedeutung knüpfte übrigens auch an das
ist in Deutschland gar nicht so groß
wahrgenommen worden ein großes
militärisches Manöver mit über 30.000
Soldaten an der OST
australischen Küste kürzlich
überwiegend von australischen
amerikanischen Soldaten da waren auch
noch zwölf andere Nationen dabei unter
anderem auch Deutschland mit und 200
Soldaten also der Fokus auf diese
Weltregion der nimmt immer stärker zu
ja und von der außenpolitischen
Dimension dieses Themas gucken wir noch
mal so ein bisschen auf die
innenpolitische Dimension wenn man sich
so die Berichterstattung von heute und
gestern anguckt dann gibt es ja aktuell
auch Häme das jetzt nun ausgerechnet
eine grüne Außenministerin in einem
Flugzeug sitzt das 80 Tonnen Kerosin
ablassen muss wie ordnest du das ein
ähm er später hat sie eben schon mal
ausgeführt dreien umwelttechnisch ist
das wohl tatsächlich unkritisch so
schätze dass es Umweltbundesamt ein das
ja jetzt nicht unbedingt im Verdacht
steht
Gefahren für die Umwelt kleinzureden ja
insofern glaube ich kann man kann man
diesem Urteil da trauen trotzdem ist es
natürlich
unangenehm zumal für eine grünen
Politikerin zum einen weil es grüne
Lokalpolitiker sind die dieses Kerosin
rausblasen in Deutschland gerade im Raum
Frankfurt am größten deutschen Flughafen
immer wieder kritisch an man selbst wenn
es eben umwelttechnisch keine Größen
größeren Folgen habe und zum anderen hat
es natürlich einen großen Lichtkegel
darauf geworfen wie viel Sprit für
solche regierungsfliege Flüge verwendet
werden ja es waren ja allein für diesen
einen Flug das war auch nur eine
Teilstrecke vom ersten Flug
insgesamt jeweils 110 Tonnen
zugetankt worden jetzt mussten zweimal
80 Tonnen
rausgeblasen werden Kollege von der Welt
hat das mal ausgerechnet das würde für
circa 3.500 mal volltanken bei einem
Mittelklasse Diesel reichen das ist
natürlich schon noch mal ein Hinweis
darauf wie viel da tatsächlich verflogen
wird und deshalb deswegen Gewicht weil
Annalena baerbock selbst zu Beginn ihrer
Amtszeit den Vorsatz formuliert hatte
weniger zu fliegen vor allen Dingen mit
der Flugbereitschaft mehr Linie zu
fliegen was natürlich dann kleineren CO2
Abdruck bedeuten würde und diesem
Anspruch ist sie bislang nicht gerecht
geworden es hat seine Anfrage der Linken
vor einiger Zeit schon gegeben
wie häufig sie denn tatsächlich Linie
geflogen sein
Oppositionsparteien haben wir dieses
Recht solche Fragen zu stellen dann muss
die Bundesregierung dann auch Antworten
die Antwort war bei den ersten 69 Flügen
war das zweimal der Fall und seitdem das
war ein märz ist jetzt genau ein
weiterer L inienflug hinzugekommen heute
nämlich notgedrungen der Rückflug
ja danke Daniel bis hierhin eine Frage
habe ich jetzt noch die uns alle
interessiert und zwar wann und wie geht
es denn für dich jetzt zurück
wir fliegen morgen früh zurück es geht
können wir ein bisschen mit der Zeit
Durcheinander bei uns ist es hier jetzt
10 Uhr abends also zwei Stunden voraus
sozusagen um 4 Uhr geht's Richtung
Flughafen und dann
logischerweise auch Berliner dann über
Istanbul zurück nach Berlin
dann wünschen wir dir hier
ein Danke dass du die Fragen von uns von
unserer Community beantwortet hast und
bis bald sehr gerne vielen Dank
ja mittlerweile also alle wieder zurück
unser Kollege zurück auch anderen in der
Werbung zurück von dieser Reise die sie
nicht antreten konnte wie es dahin
gehend weitergeht ob diese
Flugbereitschaft weiterhin von so Pannen
gebeutelt wird ihr werdet es bei uns auf
jeden Fall erfahren danke für eure
Fragen und Kommentare und bis bald